so are there ever times when you've
questions should i began a 40-hour week
job is there a plan B no there can't be
a plan B least not for me if there's a
plan B I'll go to plan B I had to I've
been a working actor for 16 years now 12
on stage three and a half here in LA and
I haven't had a day job because at least
for me if I don't cut the Maureen's and
just say that's it this is my profession
I'll even make it our own then I won't
do it and so what motivates me to get up
in the morning has been 10 to 12 hours
on social media and work a 14-hour day
doing nothing but sitting in front of
the damn computer trying to figure out
on a market myself what motivates me is
the the need to eat and that's good
that's really good because if I did this
as a hobby that's exactly what it would
be a hobby I'm Michael Caine keep going
back to because he wrote the best book
on film acting ever Michael Caine said
if you're going to make it in film it
cannot be just a full-time job it has to
be a full-time obsession and that's
that's what it is it has to be that's
great was there ever a time you were
close to quitting yes the first couple
of years before I would have found my
brand and what I what I did well on
camera there were times when I couldn't
afford the peanut butter well I had to
decide between crunchy peanut butter and
the smooth peanut butter and do I get
bread to go with it or can I just spoon
it that kind of a thing um yeah it was
really really tough it was brutal but
because I've cut the Maureen's I got
nothing to go back to this is what I do
for a living this is all I know how to
do I don't know how to do anything else
and I know I can do it on the stage and
make a good living on stage but I don't
want to go back to stage so just fought
on pressed on parade who called my
people back home and ask for
encouragement keep on keep on I think
for an actor trying to make it in a like
you can't have some long-term plan and
say if I don't make it in six months I
won't make it it's day to day because
here in LA the magic thing is at any
time the phone can ring and it could be
something wonder
and that's not true anywhere else in the
country for a film actor this is it
you